Nous dormions quatre heures le matin et travaillions le reste de la journée,
en triant, identifiant et étêtant les moustiques
afin de les analyser au labo et vérifier s'ils étaient infectés de malaria
dans le sang de leurs pièces buccales.
Ainsi nous pouvions non seulement connaître la proportion de malaria
mais aussi quels moustiques transportaient la malaria.
Nous pouvions aussi savoir si la malaria
était principalement à l'intérieur ou à l'extérieur des maisons.
Aujourd'hui, Mesdames et Messieurs,
je gagne ma vie en attrapant des moustiques.
Mais je le fais surtout pour améliorer la vie et le bien-être des gens.
Il est appelé par certains l'animal le plus dangereux sur terre.
Ce qui est malheureusement vrai.
Mais que savons-nous des moustiques ?
Nous en savons en fait peu de choses.
Il faut savoir que pour l'instant le meilleur outil contre la malaria
est la moustiquaire traitée à l'insecticide.
Nous savons qu'à travers l'Afrique
la résistance aux insecticides est répandue.
Et que ces mêmes insecticides,
de la classe des pyréthrinoïdes, sont vaporisés sur ces moustiquaires.
Nous savons que ces moustiquaires protègent contre les piqûres
mais tuent seulement une partie des moustiques.
Cela signifie que nous devons faire plus pour atteindre le zéro.
Et cela fait partie de notre mission.
A l'Institut de Santé Ifakara,
nous nous concentrons sur la biologie du moustique
pour identifier de nouvelles possibilités. Une nouvelle approche.
De nouvelles options
en plus de celles que l'on a déjà comme les moustiquaires
pour atteindre le zéro.
Je vais vous donner quelques exemples
de ce que mes collègues et moi faisons.
En voici un exemple.
Les moustiques se reproduisent dans des petits bassins d'eau.
Ils ne sont pas tous faciles à trouver ––
ils sont répartis à travers les villages,
ils sont aussi petits qu'une trace de pas.
Ils peuvent être aussi bien près que loin de votre maison.
Donc, si vous voulez contrôler des larves de moustique,
cela peut être difficile de les attraper.
Ce que mes collègues et moi avons décidé de faire,
c'est d'utiliser les moustiques eux-mêmes
pour transporter des insecticides de l'endroit de notre choix
vers leurs propres lieux de reproduction
pour qu'aucun œuf ne puisse survivre.
Voici Dickson Lwetoijera.
C'est mon collègue qui mène la barque à Ifakara.
Il a habilement prouvé qu'on peut faire en sorte que les moustiques
se déplacent à l'endroit habituel afin de récupérer du sang
pour qu'ils prennent une dose de stérilisant ou d'insecticide,
le transportent vers leur lieu de reproduction
et tuent leur progéniture.
Nous avons démontré qu'on peut anéantir des populations très très rapidement.
C'est beau.
C'est notre ville pour moustiques.
La plus grande ferme à moustiques au monde
destinée à la recherche sur la malaria.
Ici, nous avons des colonies autonomes et à grande échelle de moustiques
que nous élevons dans ces installations.
Bien sûr, ils n'ont pas de maladie.
Mais ces systèmes nous permettent
d'introduire de nouveaux outils et de les tester immédiatement,
très rapidement,
et voir si nous pouvons anéantir ou contrôler ces populations.
Mes collègues ont démontré que si l'on met en place
deux ou trois endroits où les moustiques peuvent récupérer ces substances létales,
nous pouvons détruire ces colonies en seulement trois mois.
On appelle cela l'auto-dissémination.
Et si nous pouvions utiliser
le comportement sexuel des moustiques
pour également les contrôler ?
D'abord, vous devez savoir
que les moustiques s'accouplent en ce qu'on appelle des « essaims ».
Les moustiques mâles se rassemblent en groupes autour de l'horizon
habituellement au coucher du soleil.
Les mâles y mènent une danse,
les femelles rejoignent cette danse et prennent le mâle de leur choix,
d'habitude le plus beau à leurs yeux.
Ils s'attachent ensemble et tombent par terre.
Observer cela, c'est merveilleux : un phénomène fantastique.
(Rires)
C'est là où la capture de moustiques devient intéressante
Nous avons vu en allant chasser des essaims dans les villages,
que ces essaims ont tendance à se trouver exactement au même endroit
chaque jour, chaque semaine, chaque mois, année après année.
Ils commencent exactement au même moment, chaque soir,
et ils se situent aux mêmes emplacements.
Qu'est-ce que cela nous indique ?
Cela signifie que si l'on établit une carte à travers les villages,
nous pourrions détruire ces populations d'un seul coup.
D'une certaine manière, nous pourrions les atomiser d'un seul coup de spray.
C'est ce que nous essayons de faire avec de jeunes gens dans les villages.
Nous organisons ces équipes, leur enseignons à identifier les essaims,
et à les pulvériser.
Mes collègues et moi pensons que c'est une nouvelle tactique
pour chasser les moustiques de la vallée.
Mais peut-être le fait que les moustiques se nourrissent de sang, du sang humain,
explique qu'ils soient l'animal le plus dangereux sur terre.
Mais si nous considérons que les moustiques peuvent nous sentir,
et qu'ils ont développé d'incroyables organes sensoriels.
Ils peuvent nous sentir jusqu'à 100 mètres de distance
Et quand ils se rapprochent,
ils peuvent même distinguer deux membres de la même famille.
Ils savent qui vous êtes d'après les odeurs que vous produisez,
l'haleine, la peau, la sueur et le corps.
Ce que nous avons fait à Ifakara,
c'est d'identifier ce qui, dans la peau, le corps, la sueur ou l'haleine,
attire ces moustiques.
Une fois ces substances identifiées, nous avons créé une concoction,
une sorte de mélange de substances synthétiques
qui ressemblent à ce que le corps produit.
Nous avons créé un mélange synthétique
qui attire trois à cinq fois plus de moustiques qu'un être humain.
Que faire avec cela ?
On place un piège pour attraper plein de moustiques et on les tue ?
Et bien sûr, on peut aussi faire un monitoring.
À Ifakara,
nous aimerions étendre nos connaissances sur la biologie du moustique ;
pour contrôler beaucoup d'autres maladies, dont la malaria,
mais aussi d'autres maladies transmises par les moustiques
comme la dengue, le chikungunya et le virus Zika.
C'est pourquoi mes collègues, par exemple ––
nous avons vu que certains moustiques aiment piquer sur la région de la jambe.
Et nous avons créé des sandales qui repoussent les moustiques
que les touristes et les habitants de la région peuvent porter.
Et ils ne se font pas piquer.
Cela donne une protection toute la journée
jusqu'au moment d'aller au lit sous la moustiquaire.
(Applaudissements)
Ma relation entre amour et haine avec les moustiques continue.
(Rires)
Et c'est bien parti pour durer.
Mais cela me va.
L'OMS s'est fixé pour objectif d'ici 2030 d'éliminer la malaria de 35 pays.
L'Union Africaine s'est fixée pour objectif
d'ici 2030 d'éliminer la malaria du continent.
A Ifakara, nous soutenons fermement ces objectifs.
Et nous avons réuni un groupe de jeunes scientifiques,
hommes et femmes, toutes et tous des champions,
qui souhaitent se réunir pour faire de cette vision une réalité.
Ils font tout ce qu'ils peuvent pour y parvenir.
Et nous les soutenons.
Nous sommes ici pour faire en sorte que ces rêves se réalisent.
Mesdames et Messieurs,
même si cela ne se fera pas de notre vivant,
même si cela ne se réalise pas
avant que vous et moi partions, je crois que vos enfants et les miens
pourront hériter d'un monde sans moustiques porteurs de malaria
et sans malaria.
Merci beaucoup, Mesdames et Messieurs.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
K. Kubu : Fredros,
Parlons un peu de CRISPR.
(Rires)
CRISPR a conquis le monde
et promet de faire des choses incroyables.
Que pensez-vous des scientifiques qui l'utilisent contre les moustiques ?
Fredros Okumu : Pour répondre, prenons le problème à la base.
Tout d'abord, nous parlons d'une maladie qui tue encore ––
d'après les derniers chiffres que nous avons de l'OMS ––
429 000 personnes.
La plupart sont des enfants africains.
Bien sûr, nous avons progressé,
il y a des pays qui ont réussi à réduire de 50 à 60 % le fléau de la malaria.
Mais nous avons encore beaucoup à faire pour atteindre zéro.
Nous avons déjà la preuve du principe selon lequel
les techniques de manipulation génétique comme CRISPR,
peuvent être utilisées efficacement afin de transformer les moustiques,
pour que, soit ils ne transmettent pas la malaria ––
nous appelons cela l'altération de la population ––
ou qu'ils cessent d'exister.
La suppression de la population.
Cela est déjà prouvé en laboratoire.
Il y a aussi du travail de modélisation
qui a démontré que même si l'on devait relâcher
seulement un petit nombre de ces moustiques génétiquement modifiés
l'on pourrait parvenir à l'élimination très, très rapidement.
Donc les outils comme CRISPR constituent de vraies opportunités
pour des interventions à impact élevé
que nous pouvons utiliser en plus de ce que nous avons déjà
pour éventuellement atteindre zéro.
Cela est important.
Bien sûr, les gens nous demandent toujours ––
ce qui est une question courante,
j'imagine que vous allez la poser également ––
que se passera-t-il si on éradique les moustiques ?
KK : Je ne la poserai pas alors, j'écoute votre réponse.
FO : À ce sujet, j'aimerais rappeler à mes collègues
que nous avons 3 500 différentes espèces de moustiques dans le monde.
Peut-être plus que cela.
Environ 400 d'entre eux sont anophèles,
et environ 70 parmi eux ont la capacité de transmettre la malaria.
En Afrique, nous avons affaire à seulement trois ou quatre d'entre eux.
Ils transmettent 99 % de toute la malaria.
Si nous devions utiliser la manipulation génétique, comme CRISPR,
ou des vecteurs génétiques,
nous nous en prendrions à seulement un ou deux.
Je ne vois pas de problème de diversité avec cela.
Mais c'est mon point de vue.
Souvenez-vous, d'ailleurs,
de toutes ces années passées à tenter d'éliminer efficacement ces moustiques
en les pulvérisant –– nos collègues en Amérique l'ont fait ––
en utilisant de véritables bombes de spray pour chasser ces insectes.
En Afrique, nous employons beaucoup de spray à la maison.
Tout cela est destiné seulement à tuer les moustiques.
Il n'y aurait aucun problème avec un nouvel outil.
Mais cela dit,
nous devons aussi être très, très responsables.
Donc il y un côté réglementaire,
et nous devons travailler avec nos régulateurs
pour que tout ce que nous faisons soit fait correctement,
de manière responsable,
et que tous les risques soient évalués indépendamment,
pour veiller à ce que cela ne tombe pas en de mauvaises mains.
Merci beaucoup.
KK : Merci.
(Applaudissements)